For example, research shows that beautiful people earn about 10% more money
over the course of their lives. They also tend to have more friends, more sex,
and more dates than non beautiful people. Moreover, research has shown that
some people believe that beautiful people also have superior personal
qualities. Now it turns out that beautiful people may actually have better
opportunities, and more friends for social interaction. And therefore their
social skills can be better than less beautiful people. This doesn't just hold
true for how we behave as adults in interacting with other people. But research
has found that mothers tend to be more affectionate and playful with their
children, when they're attractive as compared to when they're unattractive. So
this leads us to the question, what is beautiful?